Ще одна надзвичайна ситуація.
Співробітники серцевого центру Лейпцига постійно напоготові.
Пацієнти тут у важкому стані.
Вони в черзі за донорськими серцями.
6 місяців тому Андре Веберу сказали, що він довго не проживе без нового серця.
- Неясно, як довго мені доведеться чекати.
Мабуть, від шести місяців до року. Щодня боюся, що
не доживу, бо тримаюся тільки на великих дозах медикаментів.
Карстен Це - нині затятий велосипедист.
А 11 років тому йому пересадили серце у цій самій клініці.
Тоді список очікування органів не був таким довгим
і було більше донорів.
- Найбільше, що змінилося, - це час очікування.
Тоді я шість тижнів був у терміновому списку.
Сьогодні ж найбільш нагальні випадки чекають від 6 місяців до року.
Це жахливі зміни в гірший бік.
Щорічно в Європі вмирають тисячі людей,
так і не дочекавшись донорського органу.
Минулого року в Німеччині було загалом 769 донорів,
тоді як лише на одну нирку черга - майже 8 тисяч німців.
Доктор Свен Лєманн роз’яснює родичам
невиліковно хворих пацієнтів важливість передачі органів.
- Ми повинні зробити так, щоб люди усвідомлювали,
що наше повсякденне завдання - рятувати життя та лікувати пацієнтів.
І що люди отримують шанс вилікуватися,
якщо ми будемо надавати їм свої органи.
48-річний Андре Вебер обговорив проблему донорства зі своєю родиною.
Він вважає, що німецька система, за якою взяти орган можна лише тоді,
коли підписана згода у письмовій формі,
застаріла й бюрократична.
- Я чув, що 80% німців виступають за донорство органів,
але лише 30% мають донорську картку.
Чому б не запровадити презумпцію згоди, коли
без офіційної заяви "проти" внутрішні органи померлого
можуть бути автоматично трансплантовані.
Це, безсумнівно, допоможе багатьом людям.
Карстен Це працює в асоціації пацієнтів
із трансплантацією серця та легень.
Він допомагає доглядати за тими, хто переніс пересадку органів.
Також Карстен проводить кампанію за презумпцію згоди
і сам є живим доказом того, що жертвувати органи варто.